foreign
and talk to the great DJ what's Up DJ
hey how are you good oh good I thought
it was DJ Jazzy Jeff and The Fresh
Prince it is not thank goodness no it is
DJ laryngitis what's going on right now
excellent
I feel like I'm the one that's been
partying but I have not been you have DJ
and it's okay it's a safe space on the
show I don't even think the show is
quite a safe based but hey you're good
you're good we will we will pull up a
seat for somebody with laryngitis no
problem what's up
so long short of it I I met a great man
um through a mutual friend he was in the
middle of a messy divorce so I did not
pursue anything
um and we uh I was there more of the
supportive role we kind of realized we
liked each other and we saw each other
about every
um every two weeks given my custody
Arrangement and um in his you know
during his separation so we are three
months after his divorces final and
um you know this has been almost a year
now that we've been talking and been
there for each other and I'm just
wondering
um I brought up intentions and that I
wanted to build something significant
with someone and was wondering if he saw
that potential for us
and along with that would be you know
introducing our children eventually and
not not for a while still and
um just kind of wondering uh you know
what do I do now just step back and
keep the ball in his court and let him
figure out what he wants and uh go from
there how long have you been divorced
um let's see my son's four and a half so
we've been divorced
um but it's been over two years but
we've been separated since my son lives
almost a month old okay
is this your first
time you've been dating or is this just
the first time you've dated somebody and
you're like I don't like this guy
first time
I don't recommend it
um but yeah this is the first
um guy that you know is is really just a
wonderful man and you know when I see
these things it's we have the same roles
we grew up the same way with you know in
a Christian home and we have similar
values on with how we want to raise our
children and uh he's kind and you know
chemistry is there too so it's all the
good things
um I know he's going through a lot yeah
what's what's the
do you feel this
um
and again I'm not saying this like
talking down I'm saying it's like just
imagine you and I are sitting at a table
and we're both cracking up okay
all right do you feel like okay I've
been on on oh gosh the words I'm using
here are really obnoxious and so just
for the Casual listeners I'm being
obnoxious on purpose
you've been on the market for two years
and you see this guy and you're like
these guys don't come around and so I
want to lock it down
or do you feel like a soul connection
with somebody after a year
like what what's what's the rush to not
just have a great time for the next year
laughing and carrying on and going on
dates and being goofy and playing
pickleball and going to concerts and
whatever
yeah you know there is no rush because
I've checked the boxes in my life I've
gotten married I've had a child team
with him you know we don't want more
children we've talked about these things
and yeah yeah yeah there is no rush no
I'm 39. I'm I'm done
oh sister when you sit in the seat off
the dog
it's good
um you know and he does feel like
somewhat of a unicorn just because of um
you know meeting all the marks I mean
goodness being able to agree with
someone on the way you raise children
that's that's hard enough as it is
um so I I get I 100 get that
my concern for you is
in your words messy divorce
it was just it was ugly for him
um his wife started seeing a neighbor
and around this person
um before he ever knew it was even going
on
and then there was no um custody fight
and a whole mess separating this thing
yes sir yeah so I think there's gonna
have to be some trauma processing on his
side
because the person he went all in on
took his chips that he cashed in on the
table and handed him to the neighbor
and then quite literally fought him over
it
and bargained with the kids
yeah yeah it was terrible right so he's
been through it and he's gonna have a
physiological reaction to it what I
don't want for you is you to be a safe
like warm place to land for a minute
right until he can catch his breath and
then be like all right now because
you're gonna get really hurt in that
process
oh yeah so I think you are super Super
Wise to say hey I'm I am I'm being
honest I'm going all in I'm taking a
risk
I've got long-term intentions here
but also
he needs to have the space to say I I
yeah I want to love somebody again but
right now my face is still burned from
what just happened
right right and I don't think either one
of those two things means anything other
than
cool we're just gonna be able to hang
out and have fun
and he's awesome and you think he's a
smoke show that's all good I I I'm just
I'm worried about him if he called my
show and said I just went through a
really messy divorce in the process I
met someone who was awesome my first
words to him would be slow down
yeah that didn't that first words to him
right and at the same time I also know
you're like oh dude the Unicorn I love
how you said that because that's you
being honest
I've got a couple of folks of people's
people who I love who are divorced or
recently divorced or going through the
process and their experience is very
much like your experience like oh awful
I did not know Humanity was like this
yeah it's really it's really
disappointing
um but you know I I just don't I don't
have any rush into
wanting to like I need to be in a
relationship or I need someone in my
life and I've told him that I was like
look I don't need you but but I want you
in my life that's awesome that's a
perfect thing to say I love that I love
that and I don't want you to get
devastated if he says I want you in my
life but we're gonna do it real real
slow
or I just want to hold hands with
somebody that's not going to stab me in
the back or I just want to
smooch somebody that's not you know I
mean like I I just I want to go to
movies and and do whatever that
like just the slow play in I I just I
just I don't know I think that just
feels right right now
yeah
I gotcha
and I know it's disappointing because
it'd be awesome if he was like I'm free
from an evil person and you DJ you
laryngitis and all will you marry me and
that'd be cool
yeah good for you it's okay
it took me I went through a nasty um
divorce myself from an alcoholic and I'm
still dealing with you know him and his
issues but
um you know the limited amount of time
we have to see each other I have my son
um have primary custody and he spends
one overnight with his dad every other
week so
um it's made me take things slow which
is great that's really great that's
awesome awesome awesome
good for you
um
yeah I think the best thing I think I
think the best is it okay to still
initiate oh I mean I think the best
thing to do is to be authentic and and
upfront and honest and really press him
to be upfront honest too
right okay
and I think it's important to call out
both of y'all are burn victims at this
point
yeah similar hurts yeah you got similar
hurts and so give each other permission
to say wow my body is going full trauma
mode right now my body is going full Run
for the Hills right now and that doesn't
mean anything about DJ or about him that
means you got a body that's just saying
hey we've been down this road before
remember and almost got us killed how
about we don't do that yeah and yeah the
only way towards laughter and peace and
fun is to go right through it again and
you if this thing works
you're gonna have to open your heart and
be vulnerable to another guy and he
could yeah
Scorch you and vice versa
and so you're gonna have to practice and
slow play that
it's gonna be scary and it could be
awesome
I think almost everything that's worth
it is scary right always always
and
it sounds that sounds good on Instagram
and scary things kill you too right they
they destroy everything so I think
that's that's the great the great of
life is
all the good stuffs man on the other
side of the storm all the good stuff's
on the other side of ah
and
there's bears and tigers on the other
side of the storm too right it's both in
so it's I'm gonna get a group of people
to go with me through this thing you
know what if I had one piece of wisdom
for you and him it would be to make sure
you all have
a couple of people in your life that's
not each other that will just hang out
go get nachos and a beer go hang out
just do whatever
um that there is not gonna be all of
this pressure to make this thing your
only friendship
um that would be really helpful and
you'll have somebody to talk to I like
him I like him and he can be like I
think I like her and their butt your
buddies can be like you're crazy or or
not whatever but I think having some
people in your life just to walk with
you just to be your friends just to be
your friends hang out have fun
um
but I'll tell you this
I've talked to a lot of people in this
situation and you're about as wise as
they come DJ
good for you thank you for being honest
and upfront and best of luck to you guys
um holler at me anytime if I can help